what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here and I'm John we are going to watch
a trailer right now for a movie that
we're going to the premiere of in about
an hour we're gonna watch this trailer
because we got invited over like that
sounds cool we heard some people who are
involved and that sounds awesome and
then it hit us we haven't even seen the
trailer for the movie
so everybody's reaction to it we're not
gonna do a whole trailer review cuz
we're gonna go watch it we'll just come
back slap it out right after the
reaction you'd be like a review and a
trailers revisited all in one called the
fury of the fist and the Golden Fleece
there's a lot of people interested the
arothron in it is growing up oh my god
Danny Trejo cool more 70 Rafael Reif Lee
skimmed over the description of this
this is watch this
[Music]
[Music]
consciousness justice electricity
sent you what are you talking about you
came here
yeah stone michael duty calls
bianca van Damme we keep Ryoga battling
jab uncle bird ron jeremy yeah Ray's
done fried on the dragon Wilson with
tiny Lister and time on and Danny Trejo
whoo yeah you are the fittest and the
Golden Fleece the time has come and I'm
coming with him
[Music]
okay man well at the time of filming
this it is May 24th oh it's really fun
I'm excited to go watch this now looks
wild I almost don't know what to expect
gonna intervene it's it's one of them
poopy grindhouse
type of films so the lot of mayhem in it
I'm sure this is gonna be a fun time at
the movie theaters like as a near kung
fury or something like that
oh yeah wild off-the-wall that I like
this this seems like my kind of film
well well let's go watch it and we'll be
right back
[Music]
alright so we just got back from the
movie it's 1:45 in the morning for us
right now interesting experience at the
theater guys they were having issues
playing the movie I've been to premieres
and screenings where that's happened
before stuff happen in the Neal harm
started because someone decided as smoke
a cigarette or something in the bathroom
at the theater the fire alarm is going
off this is the greatest night I've had
in a long time
you know what the highlight of my
experiences though as you can see in the
reaction I said oh Cynthia Rothrock is
in this movie Cynthia Rothrock in it I
wasn't growing up oh my god I go to get
my seat
sure enough I am sitting directly next
on the right side of me is Cynthia
Rothrock I gotta talk to her for like 45
minutes to an hour because it took a
while for the movie to start Oliver
Stone was there cuz the star of this
Sean Stone that's his son Michael jy was
there because there's right behind me
yeah I laughed at his jokes most
interaction I have Logan Paul there's a
lot of people a lot of people so it was
a cool experience the movie itself let's
put it like this you guys watch the
trailer with us we do a segment here
called trailers revisited where we take
a trailer we basically do an analysis to
see how accurately portrayed was the
movie based off the trailer totally
stylistic this trailer 100% represents
the movie yea Majan that trailer of what
you saw that's an hour and 45 minutes
right there of that yeah you looked at
that trailer and went that's for me then
you will have probably a good time with
this yeah just as hyperkinetic that is
there's so much eighties references in
this film it is insane and off the walls
and chock full of grindhouse
oh sure kung fury meets machete meets
all those right
things to a whole other degrees if you
weren't a fan of those kinds of movies
you won't be a fan of this but if you
were a fan of those kinds of films and
this is probably your kind of thing
because it is 100% that to the max if
you're a lover of any kind of you know
become food be sci-fi if you just love
like a pulpy slimy b-movie and if you
especially love the the wave of movies
now that are nostalgic for that I feel
like that is the target you know for you
if you are in that part of the Venn
diagram of you know movie interests I
feel like you might get something pretty
fun out of this it's hyperkinetic and
there are plenty of moments where the
audience is really cracking up what a
crash zooms yeah crazy stock footage a
lot of lightning bolt effects and
different things a lot of easy fights
and they put a lot of editing into this
film man we're not gonna break it down
into like a whole review of a movie
format because you could just watch it
on demand right now or you can jump on
the internet right now or go to the
theater it's going in a couple theaters
around town - there's a itunes link to
go download the movie right now in the
description box for you guys because
this movie's not exactly about story
it's about those things in the trailer
that you watched of just having a
Rock'em Sock'em good time with some
craziness in it yeah you wanna have as
any wild good time you know get some
mates together have like a Saturday
midnight movie or something like that
you know grab a few drinks that you like
you'll probably have you know a pretty
solid timeline absolutely especially
again if you like the weird earmarks of
B movies especially from the 70s and 80s
and if you like references to those
things too because there are plenty of
little Easter eggs and and surprises
they toss in here nothing was left out
thank you to Comedy Dynamics for letting
us to this we had a really good time
with the premiere and you guys can go
ahead check it out and let us know what
you think of the movie yourself you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and hopefully you
guys have a good time